[Music]
mike cult has actually got a good show
that's a guy who actually does i do
radio it brings people in all right
drew garoppolo said i do radio too
should we see the clip
where where mike call to kick gallagher
out of his studio no
it's one of the funniest clips ever man
why did he kick him out because he was
you know gallagher can be difficult oh
yeah being being uh being
avant-garde for someone who not even
avant-garde but you know sometimes he's
just
not in a good mood like the one with him
and patrice dude gallagher's mood
has a lot to do with how this inter you
know your interview with him is going to
go and he wasn't in a mood that day
and uh and uh mike carlton said to him
and like i still remember as i watched
this clip i actually tweeted it it's how
i became cool with my call to before i
lost my twitter account
um was he i played the clip and i was
tweeting him about it but uh
he basically goes like you know what man
why don't you just get out
just get the [ __ ] out why don't you go
out and smash some watermelons in the
hallway and you just kicked him out of
his [ __ ] it was really funny
hold on let me see because now i gotta
yeah my copter doesn't take any [ __ ] i
like him
uh michael to interview coward
yeah it's 13 minutes so it's towards the
end i'm assuming probably yeah
sorry let me it's just it just seems to
just be is it audio or is it
no i remember seeing it oh here it is i
found it i found it i found it i found
that i found it i found it sorry
i thought it was yeah this is it
go smash your fruit in the hole all
right go back a little bit all right
bye bye you gotta go back out because
this is where it gets awkward here we go
it's gonna start around here yeah yeah
this should be about it
what did you do i did the put the
stopper in the long neck bottle wrong
and it twisted and went through my hand
oh jesus but that was repaired to tampa
general my
mother worked at tampa general as the
admitting nurse so yeah
everybody had to talk to her when they
went to the hospital no kim
yeah back in those old days uh gallagher
is here with us you believe you've been
on the show i mean i know you have once
before
and it was uh we had a phone connection
it was a horrible phone connection
we we started talking about i i told you
that i
for years when your specials came out i
had believed as i was a kid that you
were eddie haskell
from leave at the beaver did you did
that ever get back to you did you know
that
no but what a wonderful little story
that was that was i never watched sleep
with the beaver you know it was before
my time
and uh that was like that i remember
when we watched a special in my in my
grandmother's house that was the rumor
that went and i couldn't confirm or deny
you didn't know who the hell i
asked was so i grew up thinking that for
a while
okay good yeah where does this story go
say that's your problem
it doesn't go anywhere and you can't
just tell about a memory
you could ask people if they have a
memory that goes to a dead end
but i mean where do where do we go with
this now why don't we have to
now i am mad for my cult because i i
mean i know what it's like to try to do
an interview and try to get like
a nice guy trying to get the best out of
somebody it's a fun little anecdote eh
i was a kid i actually tell you already
that's actually not a pointless thing
if you're working with somebody who's
not a that's not a dead end that's when
they go you really thought i was eddie
that's [ __ ] strange that guy's guy's
actually older than me or younger than
me or whatever
you do a little thing you go you know i
was leaving to beaver fan i don't look
anything
you weirdo you little weirdo you thought
i was eddie haskell i didn't even look
at anything i gotta
you [ __ ] but when you are dealing with
somebody who's in a mood
then it's a dead end now watch it
because
many many radio hacks would be like
you know i was just trying to give you a
story he's
my cult is having none of this watch
what happens
to go somewhere why can't i just tell
you something funny that happened in my
life
why are you being a dick right away i
just well i don't know
but the eddie i don't know wait hold on
back it up why are you turning into a
dick to me i didn't do anything to you
and all of a sudden you come in with an
attitude
right away you get [ __ ] fresh i don't
have an attitude you
kind a little bit no not kind of a lot a
bit he's still
like he's still he's still trying to
maintain
radio confessions this is remember this
is morning radio it's a syndicated
morning radio on fm so
right what's he gonna do you can't call
gallagher a [ __ ] watermelon smashing
you know what i mean like you gotta so
you're like hey look yeah
you're being a little bit of a dick
there somebody goes gallagher just gets
in a funk when watermelons are out of
season
all right great okay all right gal yours
nice seeing you
go smash your fruit in the hole oh
god yeah
yeah go smash your fruit in the
hall and that was that was like i
because i've always had back and forth
with my cult ever since i got into radio
and so he's just one of the guys i liked
and respected
honestly ever since he when he popped on
o and [ __ ] back in the day i thought he
was funny
um and when that happened dude i
remember tweeting him and being like
dude
that was [ __ ] so he'd take his [ __ ]
for nothing
wow and then you know gallagher was
being a dick
yeah there was no reason for that he was
being a dick
all right bye bye yeah see you later
good good your peg's still on your hat
mini pearl
but you know what you knew that's that's
what why did what happened in the hall
uh his manager was just asking and
telling us all the details about this
and that took him so why did that well
he was very
insistent that the other two come with
him because it makes for the better
she's cute well clearly gallagher
couldn't put on which is good because
like every
every woman in radio is a [ __ ] mess
yeah every local
rock dj that you think is cute when you
see them like at the concert
they're disgusting women in the sales
department are always odds like one of
the only attractive women i've ever seen
in radio
i can't believe that i agreed to have
gallagher on the show and he was no
zombo goes don't disrespect us man he's
a great arcade game you're thinking of
gallagher
gallagher yeah which by the way also not
a great argument
no just a dick like that that was pretty
crazy if his name was mortal kombat 3
then maybe a great arcade game pass it
like i was not going to do anything yeah
okay you ready you got you ready for the
truth now
so evidently gallagher is doing this
show and they buy advertising on another
radio station they sell no tickets
so they come to us at the last minute
and they said is there any way you would
have gallagher on the show
because we are desperately trying to
sell tickets that's some inside base oh
boy this is this is also again i
hate most radio people i've always liked
mike kalter because he really
has a shitty attitude sometimes i've
never heard this before this is this is
and gallagher's got an interesting story
about with his brother and his brother
taking over for him
and going out on the road and i said
yeah i'd be i'd be willing and then he
sued his brother by the way
gallagher sued his brother talk to him
about that
no idea by the way that he was coming in
at 7 7 10 in prime time in the morning
or 7 30 or whatever
and then he comes in and i'm nothing but
nice to him trying to get some
background
because he's from tampa and then he's
gonna be a dick to me he's gallagher
he didn't even have his goddamn
sledgehammer he's gonna be a tough guy
and where is this gonna go
where it's gonna go is did you ever hear
that or were there any other stories
that you heard about yourself like that
that weren't true that you know you
would you
talk like mark dice that's actually
young mark jace i'd like to know what he
thought while he was in here doing those
things
calm down dude all right
you got in my head about this next thing
but we got to do it right the other
little anecdote i wanted to share about
this guy was that years ago he um
he was on a station that they were going
to flip formats and fire everybody
but they were like don't do it's a
secret don't say just just carry on like
normal
we're going to reassign everybody new
jobs so then he went on the
on the air because it was going to be a
spanish language station and he did the
whole show in spanish
the next day didn't address it
he just did his regular show but in
spanish which was really funny